there are a number of business benefits
that go along with moving applications
to the cloud and certain workloads are
easier than others
apps running in the cloud require a
variety of storage solutions including
block file or object storage
and in some cases a combination
ultimately you need to find the
appropriate storage architecture for
each need because you can't rewrite
every app to use one type of storage nor
should you
from a cloud ops viewpoint where you
store is just as important as what you
store if you choose to use storage
options from multiple companies or work
with third party providers you'll be
juggling multiple uis setup requirements
and access points
not to mention setting up multiple im
cmec and other security policies results
in context switching that can seriously
impact your team's efficiency
and let's be honest your folks would
love to have their weekends back
fortunately google cloud offers you a
full portfolio of block file and object
storage to choose from including nfs
storage solutions so you don't
compromise on an sla or business value
that you're delivering to your
organization
and if you're looking for file storage
we have multiple options to best fit
your needs
for a quick overview of the file store
product family we have file store basic
which is built for many applications
including test and dev workloads
file store high scale is excellent for
larger storage capacity requirements and
higher performance requirements that
many hpc applications need like genomic
sequencing or financial trading
analytics
file store enterprise is designed for
critical business applications like sap
and other use cases that also require
high availability
and having a simple trusted and
streamlined place to manage these
settings and get things set up cannot be
underestimated
google cloud gives you a simple yet
powerful user interface to provision
storage capacity for applications
utilizing nfs and if you're someone that
likes coding we have a single set of
file store apis you can use across the
entire file store family
and for those who need to deploy
business critical applications in the
cloud with many of the traditional
enterprise features like high
availability and integrated data
protection we've built file store
enterprise
imagine having the protection you need
but with a cloud native and fully
managed storage service that has a
regional availability sla and file
system snapshots
only in the cloud can your data be
seamlessly replicated to multiple zones
within a region all with a simplified
single point of access
and with file storage snapshots you can
rest assured that any and all of your
data can be recovered within minutes if
the unthinkable happens
for example a canadian financial
services company moved its core sap
banking systems to google cloud as it
digitally transformed its operations in
order to improve its client experiences
however they couldn't compromise with a
non-resilient storage solution
high availability is of the utmost
importance for their mission-critical
sap systems
and then there's a leading travel
reservation company that underwent an
iit modernization initiative and moved
critical applications to the cloud
they chose file store enterprise to
store and protect their information
ensuring their cloud ops and their users
could recover any of that information
when needed
no matter the demands of your
architecture or industry google cloud
has a comprehensive trusted portfolio of
block file and object storage to choose
from
and regardless of which solution fits
your needs you can keep things simple
with the unified admin console
to learn more about file store
enterprise or any of our file store
solutions check out
cloud.google.com file store
and head to the console to provision
your own file store enterprise instance
in just a few clicks today
you